[Music]
[Applause]
at last
while this companions one and all aged
him to save himself as soon as possible
from the indignities that threatened him
he bade them dig a grave in his presence
proportioned to the size of his own
person and at the same time bring winter
and wood for presently disposing of his
body as each of these things was done he
wept and said again and again what an
artist the world is losing while he
hesitated a letter was brought a faaaan
by one of his couriers Nero snatching it
from his hand read that he had been
pronounced a public enemy by the Senate
and that they were seeking Him to punish
in the ancient fashion and he asked what
manner of punishment that was when he
learned that the criminal was stripped
fastened by the neck in a fork and then
beaten to death with rods in mortal
terror he seized two daggers which he
had brought with him and then after
trying the point of each put them up
again bleeding that the fatal hour had
not yet come now he would beg spores to
begin to lament and wail now entreat
someone to help him take his life by
setting him the example and on he
reproached himself for his cowardice in
such words as these to live is a scandal
and a shame this does not become Nero
does not become him one should be
resolute at such times come rouse
thyself and now the horsemen were at
hand who had orders to take him off
alive when he heard them he quavered
Huk now strikes on my ear the trampling
of swift-footed courses and drove a
dagger into his throat aided by a
Pafford itis his private secretary
he was all but dead when a Centurion
rushed in and as he placed the cloak to
the wound pretending that he had come to
aid him
Nero merely gasped too late and this is
fidelity with these words he was gone
with eyes so set and starting from their
sockets that all who saw him shuddered
with horror first and beyond all else he
had forced from his companions a promise
to let no one have his head but to
contrive in some way that he be buried
unmute elated and this was granted by a
soulless galvez freedmen who had shortly
before been released from the bondage to
which he was consigned at the beginning
of the revolt he was buried at a cost of
two hundred thousand sister seized and
laid out in white robes embroidered with
gold which he had worn on the Kalin's of
January his ashes were deposited by his
nurses igloo J and Alexandria
accompanied by his mistress act a in the
family tomb of the de meaty on the
summit of the hill of Gardens which is
visible from the Campus Martius and that
moment his sarcophagus of porphyry
with an altar of lunar marble standing
above it is enclosed by a balustrade of
phase e'en stoned he was about the
average height his body marked with
spots and malodorous his hair like
blonde his features regular rather than
attractive his eyes blue and somewhat
weak his neck over thick his belly
prominent and his legs very slender his
health was good for though indulging in
every kind of riot a success he was ill
but three times in all during the 14
years of his reign and even then not
enough to give up wine or any of his
usual habits he was utterly famous in
the care of his person and in his dress
always having his hair arranged in tea
of curls and during the trip to Greece
also letting it grow long and hang down
behind and they often appeared in public
in a dining robe with a handkerchief
bound around his neck
Unger t' and unshod but above all he was
carried away by a craze for popularity
and he was jealous of all who in any way
stirred the feeling of the mob he was
the general belief but after all his
victories on the stage he would at the
next lustrum have competed with the
athletes at olympia pre practiced
wrestling constantly and all over greece
he'd always viewed the gymnastic
contests after the fashion of the judges
sitting on the ground in the stadium and
if any pairs of contestants withdrew too
far from their positions he would force
them forward with his own hand since he
was acclaimed as the equal of Apollo in
music and of the Sun in driving a
chariot he'd planned to emulate the
exploits of hercules as well and they
say that a lion had been specially
trained for him to kill naked in the
arena of the amphitheater before all the
people with a club or by the clasp of
his arms
[Music]